[Music]
intuition pumps are sometimes called
thought experiments more often they're
called thought experiments but they're
not really formal arguments typically
their stories their little fables in
fact I think they're similar to Aesop's
fables in that they they're supposed to
have a moral they're supposed to teach
us something and what they do is they
lead the audience to an intuition a
conclusion where you sort of pound your
fist on the table and you say oh yeah
it's got to be that way doesn't it and
if if it achieves that then it's it's
pumped the intuition that was designed
to pump these are persuasion machines
little persuasion machines that
philosophers have been using for several
thousand years I think that intuition
pumps are particularly valuable when
there's confusion about just what the
right questions are and and what the
right what what matters what matters to
answer the question I think we're all
pretty good at using examples to to
think about things and intuition pumps
are usually rather vivid examples that
are some which you're supposed to draw a
very general moral and they come up in
many walks of life any time you're
puzzled or confused about what to do
next or whether something's true or
false you might cast about for an
intuition pump that could help you when
I first coined the term intuition pump
it's when Doug Hofstadter and I were
working on the mind's eye which has lots
of intuition pumps lots of thought
experiments in it and Doug came up with
a great metaphor he said what you want
to do with any of these intuition pumps
is twiddle all the knobs turn the knobs
see what makes it work now though this
is actually something that we're
familiar with from other parts of our
lives if there's a gadget and you want
to know what it does turn the knobs see
what happens see see what the moving
parts do so I encourage everybody to not
not just to take an intuition pump as
its handed to them but look at the
moving part see see what makes it tick
try to figure out what if I adjust this
will it still pump the same intuition
well it still yield the same putative
conclusion or will the whole thing fall
apart and it's interesting to see that a
lot of times philosophers will make an
intuition pump which seems to do great
work until you start turning the knobs
and then you realize that it actually
depends on your not thinking clearly
about some aspect of the problem then
you've exposed it as as not a good
intuition pump but as actually a sort of
negative one I call them boom crutches
because they explode in your face
[Music]